schlechte nachrichten die wirklichkeit
gibt es sogar nicht es geht hier auf der
erde und im universum nicht mit rechten
dingen zu das wird das ergebnis dieses
videos seien bleibt also dran bei pixum
science fiction
habt ihr schon mal bewusst darauf
geachtet wie es sich anfühlt wenn ihr an
einem heizstrahler vorbeigeht
die wärmestrahlung fühlt sich an wie
eine kraft wie eindruck der aus einer
ganz konkreten richtung kommt dabei ist
es nur eine strahlung mit einer
bestimmten frequenz was wäre wenn unsere
ganze welt so funktionieren würde
das heißt wie strahlung übt auch die
materie eine kraft aus die einfach nur
stärker ist als alles was wir kennen so
stark dass materie nicht ineinander
dringen kann sprich zwei gegenstände
hätten theoretisch die möglichkeit sich
zu durchdringen wenn ihre strahlung ihre
strahlungs kraft nicht so stark wäre
dass sie sich abstoßen würden
genau das sagt die stringtheorie es gibt
keine teilchen
es gibt keine materie es gibt nur eine
art strahlung die strings fäden die in
einer bestimmten frequenz schwingen
genauso wie wärmestrahlung oder auch
nicht sie bilden je nach frequenz die
verschiedenen phänomene die wir als
teilchen wahrnehmen es sind aber in
wirklichkeit schwingende fäden
diese theorie löst viele rätsel
sie bringt die relativitätstheorie und
die quantenphysik zusammen und erklärt
zahlreiche phänomene
sie hat nur ein paar klitzekleine haken
es gibt bisher keinerlei beweise für die
stringtheorie und wenn sie tatsächlich
gelten würde gäbe es achtung zehn oder
elf dimensionen in denen wir leben so
wie wir die welt erleben wäre sie nicht
wirklich wir leben nur in einer illusion
und das verrückte das komplett verrückte
dabei die natur merkt wann wir auf die
finger gucken und verändert ihr
verhalten ganz so als hätten wir einen
trick des zauberers enttarnen
es gibt ein experiment das beweist dass
wir letztlich das sehen was wir säen
sollen
der physiker werner heisenberg hat schon
1927 festgestellt dass sich teilchen wie
teilchen aber auch wie wellen verhalten
also beides können je nachdem was wir
gerade beobachten also dahin wo wir
sehen da verändert die natur ihr
verhalten was ist das denn
das ist schon ein wenig gespenstisch
schicken wir nicht durch zwei spalten
passiert etwas extrem seltsames das
licht verhält sich absolut unerwartet
es verhält sich die welle es bildet
hinter diesen zwei spalten ein
interferenzmuster als würden wasser
wellen durch die spalten plätschern und
sich danach überlagern
das würde genau zu einem solchen muster
für manchen stellen verstärken sich die
wellen an anderen schwächen sie sich ab
es wird aber noch gespenstischer messen
wir hinter den spalten welchen spalt die
lichtteilchen die photonen passieren
verschwindet das interferenzmuster
plötzlich verhalten sich die teilchen
nicht mehr wie wählen sondern wie
teilchen und das nur weil wir gemessen
haben wo sich die photonen befinden
spielen wir das weiter hat dieses
experiment umwälzende folgen erst wenn
wir etwas beobachten verlässt es eine
art unscharfen zustand als red string
und wird zum teilchen zum ding
übertragen auf unserer welt so wie wir
sie erleben bedeutet dass erst dadurch
dass wir etwas beobachten entsteht es
überhaupt das was wir nicht beobachten
gibt es erstmal nicht oder es existiert
nur in einer gewissen unschärfe so gibt
es die these dass wir in einem
multiversum leben und dinge erst in dem
einen oder anderen universum entstehen
wenn sie jeweils dort beobachtet werden
eine idee ist auch dass jedes mal wenn
wir handeln ein neues universum
beziehungsweise eine weitere variation
unseres universums entsteht oder auch
dass die zahlreichen dimensionen der
sing theorien bedeuten dass es uns
einige universen gibt die wie blasen in
kochendem wasser entstehen und wieder
vergehen
es scheint aber immer wahrscheinlicher
zu sein es geht hier nicht mit rechten
dingen zu und wir müssen uns noch auf
die ein oder andere überraschung gefasst
machen
so wie wir die welt sehen ist sie nicht
schon allein deshalb weil sie sich
unterschiedlich verhält oder was meint
ihr was ist das hier ein riesiger
computer eine simulation oder eine
spielwiese für einen intelligenz die mit
uns experimentiert sind wir vielleicht
ein teil dieser existenz diskutiertes in
den kommentaren
leben wir in einer matrix wenn euch
diese ganz ähnliche these interessiert
dann schaut euch dieses video an und im
letzten video hier geht es um aliens und
zehn gründe für ihre existenz einfach
draufklicken oder auf den link in der
video beschreibung und ich freue mich
über jeden der ein kostenloses abo da
lässt und ansonsten heißt es wie immer
bis dann bleibt dran